what good is a bad man show without
Batman so apropos of them well not
apropos of nothing the new season starts
soon and I am in the process of
hopefully getting all the way through
season three before season four starts
airing I'm working on catching up but
Gotham I want to talk about Gotham
because I feel like various YouTube
channels that I watched various geek
podcasts I didn't listen to it seems
like everybody just kind of beats up on
Gotham it's a punch line go like toss
are like oh well at least it's not
Gotham or something something to that
sentiment and I love Gotham and I kind
of want to talk about why and why I
think this show is awesome now I'm gonna
preface this but before I get into
gushing about it with a couple of things
the first is I didn't always love Gotham
you go back I did a review I did a tag
team review with Ryan Daly for the very
first episode did not like it still
don't actually even though I've turned
around on the show as a whole that first
episode is still not very good and even
like vien most of the first season I'm
kind of iffy on but at this point I love
this show
so anyway the reason I mentioned that is
first of all anyone who started watching
the first season or tried to in the
first season who bailed because they
wasn't grabbing them I can't blame them
I almost didn't come back I came back
for a second episode out of morbid
curiosity and having nothing else to do
basically when it aired
if I'd been busy that might have been it
but the second episode I'm like okay
this is better and then the third
episode of Mike actually I'm starting to
see where this is going and kind of
start digging so it just it just
happened to work out well but anyone who
started it and wasn't grabbed by it I
get it fine then there's the other thing
which is people who basically have a
Batman mental block and can't get over
the idea that it's a Batman show without
Batman
and there's a lot of bit it's at this
point it's a weird criticism to me that
there's still people like but how can
you have all the Batman villains before
Batman that timeline doesn't matter okay
you this is an else world show at this
point full-on legitimate don't even
bother trying to fit this into any
existing Batman continuity it doesn't
fit it's not designed to fit and
criticizing it for not fitting a
existing Batman timeline is just you're
missing the point so if now if you can't
get out of that headspace you're also
not gonna like this show and I can't
argue with you if that's the case I mean
there are certain things certain show
certain movies that have there's like
one thing that I can't get over and that
doesn't make them bad it just makes them
something that I can't enjoy so if
people can't get over that that concept
that this is not ever gonna fit in
proper Batman continuity and you need to
treat it as an Elseworlds
with different spins on stuff if you
can't roll with that well you're not
gonna enjoy it either but if you can
there is a lot of fun to be had here so
here's why I love Gotham I'll start with
the broadest strokes because I could I
could start to get into you know
specific characters performances
episodes whatever that I really like and
I might mention some of them as I go
along but let me talk to the really big
broad strokes first of all this show is
a marriage of two aspects of comic books
and superheroes that have been around
for a very long time but are very rarely
done together which is a blending of the
dark and the ridiculous because as a
rule of thumb when comic book superhero
comic books especially go dark go in
direction of okay people are going to
die some very nasty things are gonna
happen these are these are dark damaged
characters that usually means that it
goes deadly serious in tall
and there's nothing wrong with that but
that's pretty much the only flavor of
dark that you get with superhero comic
book stories whether in the comics
themselves or in animation movies
whatever but another flavor of comic
books it's just fun just insane fun you
know day this is you know people who are
are nostalgic for like Silver Age
stories are all about this like remember
when they were fun and just crazy
adventures with wacky stuff very rarely
does fun crossover with dark and it can
be a tough marriage actually I think
maybe part of the reason it doesn't
happen more often is because frankly you
can get a severe total dissonance if you
try and marry the two but for me
Gotham marries those two so well these
are dark screwed-up people these are
messed-up characters doing messed-up
things and it is just blown up to an
almost cartoonish level where it is so
much fun and that I think is the main
core the main heart of what I love about
this show and it at this point really
no-holds-barred everything's on the
table no matter how ridiculous I mean at
this point we have had Hugo Strange
bringing people back from the dead and
we've had Mr Freeze and we've had
Firefly we've had Mad Hatter this this
thing is not afraid to just dig into the
insanity that can exist but so often
gets chucked out especially in
live-action adaptations like it's not
grounded enough it's just a little too
goofy it's like yes it's goofy but you
know what let's roll with that goofy and
I just I love that spirit of the show it
in this show is not afraid of the
ridiculous aspects of comic books and so
many adaptations of comics be it TV or
movies are afraid of the goofiness that
is inherent and a lot of superhero
stories Gotham absolu
is not afraid of it at all some specific
characters some specific my favorite
episode if I was gonna nail and as I
said I'm still catching up through
season three so I haven't I'm not
completely there but right now my
favorite episode still is season 2
episode this ball of mud and meanness
and and as I get into some of the
specifics about what I like I might get
a little bit into things that would be
considered spoilery but yeah that that
is a thing that might happen that's your
warning but this is an episode that
again really bounces those elements
because it has a great sense of fun in
this wonderful Harley Quinn esque kind
of character played by Lori petti who's
an actress who I loved anyways and then
it delves into some real serious like
really well delivered emotional depths
as Bruce confronts the man who killed
his parents and it's a great scene it's
terrific stuff love this episode to
death but in terms of some characters
who I really love I love penguin he is
he is this weird bundle of neuroses and
viciousness and he's always he's
opportunistic as heck and the show is
really kind of established that he
doesn't have like a multi-layered plan
but he will jump on an opportunity as
soon as it's in front of him and that's
how he's moving forward and advancing
and amassing power and then there's Edie
the Riddler I he took a little while to
grow on me there and that's kind of a
recurring thing there's a lot of aspects
and characters who took a little while
to really latch into me but this one I
love Edie and I think he I've really
enjoyed watching him go from just kind
of slightly annoying guy who worked for
the police and was into riddles and
watching him descend into the Riddler
more or less as we know him a character
who I hated hated in the first season
but at this point love possibly my
favorite character Barbara Kean and
that's so bizarre for me to say because
I could not stand this woman in the
first season
but then she went nuts and then she got
fun season three especially I just oh
she's so not it's great she just got
this twisted outlook on people and
emotions and love both her own and what
she sees other people and it's just oh
it's awesome it's so much fun and even
Jim Gordon at this point who again was a
character that was like what are they
doing and actually at this point in an
odd way I'm really appreciating this and
any he's they're doing things up with
him that seem very unjam Gordon like
he's got a temper he's got a notable
dark side usually Jim's Gordon's like
he's the good man in a corrupt police
department and I remember even like when
I saw the pilot bum owning the fact that
he didn't appear to be that but I'm I
watched him over the course of this show
sort of coming in trying to be the white
knight but not but being a bit too rough
and seasoned to dipping more into the
dark or end of himself in Syria in
season 3 it sort of really striving for
that ideal again I'm realizing you know
what if he stays on this getting better
path that means that by the time he is
Commissioner Gordon and again I didn't I
stand by what I said this doesn't fit
specifically into any exact continuity
but just the general idea of his
trajectory by tummy he becomes
Commissioner Gordon he could be Gordon
as we know him more or less the good man
but now I've seen this dark part of his
past that he's had and it actually
occurred to me like when you know what
if you told me that this sort of stuff
was part of Gordon's backstory and was
stuff that he over time overcame and
looked back on and said I used to be
like this I don't want to be that
anymore I probably yeah that's fine and
I just had to realize oh I'm watching
that as opposed to hearing it as a back
story and realizing that he can still
end in a place that is Gordon as I
already know and love him that just made
me up enjoy and appreciate all of this
all the more now the
not gonna say that every season has
gotten better I think again for as far
as I am in the third season the second
season is the best it has the best
balance of insanity and darkness season
three has been good it got a little bit
soap-opera II it's like in a way that
still worked it wasn't completely off
the rails and it was Gotham so it was
bizarre insane gothic kind of soap opera
but in dealing with sort of the Mad
Hatter's plotline he he shows up he does
some stuff they deal with him and then
it takes three or four episodes after
that for the Domino's to kind of finish
falling for that and during that stretch
it's a little bling yeah but then what I
knew things were picking up again when
Victor Victor says showed up again I was
like ah good we're back on track
cuz there's another character I love
more of a side character he's not shown
a ton but every time he shows up is like
oh this is gonna be fun
and that's that is the way I feel when I
watch the shows like oh this is so much
fun and it's it's okay to laugh at
slightly sick stuff which Gotham kind of
is it's a little sick but man do I have
fun with this show and if I haven't
decided yet I'm done debating this if I
catch up before the first episode of the
new season airs I might do episode
reviews as they air the way that I
normally historically have only done for
Doctor Who and Game of Thrones
we'll see that might depend partly on
reaction reception to this video because
maybe nobody cares about my feelings and
thoughts on Gotham episodes but but I'm
considering it so those are my thoughts
on Gotham why Gotham is great I just I
think it's a great show and I recognize
it is a stupid show but you know HUD a
lot of times superhero comic books are
stupid but they can still be
awesome and I feel the same way about
Gotham those are my thoughts what are
yours whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast both of those are available on
iTunes and stitcher would you like me to
do episode by episode reviews forgot
them as the episodes air if you wouldn't
definitely let me know that but in any
case until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]